[Music]
what's up
mkbhd here and this is the iphone 12
and the iphone 12 pro the ones a lot of
people have been waiting for
but also the controversial ones a little
bit because of this new unboxing
experience but you all know this was
coming apple knew this was coming
let's just get right into it also by the
way by the time you see this video i
will have been using and testing
these new iphones for a couple of days
now some into the review process
so definitely make sure you subscribe to
be able to see that right away as soon
as it comes out
and also if you're under the shirt just
shout out mcbhd.com but here we have the
two
new smaller boxes and we also have some
other stuff too that we're going to get
into that's sort of also part of the
iphone 12 story but
we'll get into that in a second but here
you go this is the new
smaller iphone box everybody's talking
about that also other iphones will start
shipping with
and we might as well get inside and see
why it's smaller
let's start with the iphone 12 product
red for this one and it really is
pretty striking visually just to see a
box that's like half the volume it
normally is because it's half the height
and as you get inside you can see the
phone is right on top
face down the footprint is basically the
whole box with a little bit of padding
so i imagine the pro max box will have
to be a little bigger
and then maybe the mini box is even
smaller but we might as well get to that
plastic peel it's pretty simple this
time
and right away that is the product red
iphone 12
looking not actually that red
but i'll get into that in a second but
let's finish the unboxing we do have
the cable here usbc to lightning the
only other stuff in the box
is the paperwork which is all in this
little half-sized pamphlets
the product red sheet the sim card
removal tool and a single sticker so
just
just one white sticker with the iphones
now
and that's it no wall brick no
headphones
just a phone and a cable in a box
basically
all right let's take a look at the
iphone 12 pro same exact size
phone so same exact size box just all
black now since the pro phones are all
with these dark themes
so the black box with blue accents for
the pacific blue phone
but yeah once you get inside phone's
right up on the top and the contents of
the box
are in fact the same no special fancy
colored stickers for the pro or anything
and no product red sheet obviously just
a phone
and a cable and that's the unboxing for
iphone 12
and iphone 12 pro so the controversy
just to address it right off the bat
is the the no charging brick in the box
apple's defense of it is it's it's an
environmental benefit
meaning they won't have to ship all
these these chargers and materials that
are just going to end up in landfills
anyway because people already own
charging bricks fair but the thing is
the wall brick that they're talking
about that they've been shipping with
the iphone since the beginning of time
that everybody has already
is the usb-a wall brick and they're
shipping
a usb-c cable with the iphone 12. the
only people that have a usb-c
wall brick are people who bought the
iphone 11. so most iphone 12 buyers that
only have the usb a wall brick will have
to also go out and buy
a usbc wall brick which apple will
conveniently sell you so
you can see how that looks either way
this is my first look at the new iphones
in person actually feeling them in the
hand and i gotta say i am
definitely a fan of the updated like
industrial design
they look and feel great to me really
solid
a little heavy actually the boxy sides
are everything
i wanted as far as taking inspiration
from the ipad pro
or even iphone 4 or iphone 5 errors of
phones
antenna lines near the corners super
tight tolerances
a flat screen pretty minimal camera bump
but not zero
i think they would have looked even
better with usb-c at the bottom but you
know
i guess we're never going to get that
but generally the square sides make it
i think more grippable like some people
may find it a little a little bit sharp
actually at first
and a little less comfortable but hey
people out here are putting cases on
every phone so i guess i shouldn't look
too much into that
but i think it looks nice it also
happens to stand up
on its own so that's pretty sweet what i
will say though is the iphone 12 pro
has the glossy stainless steel sides and
the iphone 12
has the more matte aluminum sides and i
honestly prefer
the aluminum sides like the fingerprints
you catch on stainless steel
don't look great it's the same reason i
don't want the stainless steel apple
watch i
feel like it's just a little bit neater
it's also
a little bit lighter these phones are
the exact same size and i mean
exactly the same like cases that fit one
fit the other
but the iphone 12 pro weighs 192 grams
thanks to stainless steel and an extra
camera
and the iphone 12 weighs 162. basically
i wish i could make like a hybrid
between these two builds because i also
like the satin on the back of the pro
phones
instead of this glossy back and i also
don't i feel like this isn't really red
like apple's
actually notorious for always changing
up colors so you never quite know if one
space gray
is the same as another space gray uh but
the same thing also happens with product
red
and this is the least red product red
i've seen so far
from every angle it looks much more
peach
like like red orange or coral but yeah
now you know a lot of people were
wondering what the extra cutout is on
the right side of that phone underneath
the power button since all the other
buttons are on the other side
and that is just the cutout for the 5g
antennas because yes all of these new
iphones have 5g
and that'll of course be examined in the
full review and other than that
i mean you probably already recognize
everything about these phones it's still
looking
very much like an iphone same notch up
at the top
but of course the much better looking
oled display on the iphone 12 that
essentially matches what we've seen
on these pro phones so these two phones
are as expected
very close to each other in a lot of
ways
likely on purpose and i'll get to the
price analysis
in the full review video but i want to
dive into something a little more that's
actually new with these
which is magsafe so all these new
iphones now
have magnets in the back embedded in the
wireless charging coil
for compatible accessories they're
calling it magsafe so they're bringing
the name back
and there is potential for a whole world
of new mag safe accessories that slap
onto the back of the phone
with magnets right now i don't know
about you but my first question
when i saw this was huh okay
that is going to depend entirely on how
strong these magnets actually are
so now that we have it how strong are
they and what do they like to use
well what better way to visualize what's
happening here than some good
old-fashioned
magnet paper so this is what happens
when you put magnet paper up to an old
iphone
iphone 11 there's nothing really here
except down here at the bottom which is
actually just the speakers in the bottom
of the phone
so when you put the magnet paper on an
iphone 12
boom you can immediately see these
concentric circles
and then these lines straight down them
for alignment so anything that's going
to work with magsafe and slap onto the
back of the phone and align itself
has to line up with these and i just
happen to have some magsafe accessories
here as well so
the most important one of course being
the magsafe
charger which is this thin little hockey
puck attached to a wire
with usbc at the other end it's not a
super long cable it's three feet
and the puck itself basically resembles
like a giant
apple watch charger it's flat it's metal
on the outsides
it's white plastic on the inside and it
just slaps onto the back of the phone
like this it's actually pretty much
precisely centered over the logo so it's
an easy spot to find
and it's firm but obviously since it's
just a circle it doesn't align with
those other three lines underneath so it
can spin freely which is kind of neat
and when you get it connected i believe
there's an nfc chip inside that tells
the iphone what accessory it just
connected to
and plays an animation on the screen
accordingly so when you connect just the
mag safe charger
you get just this little circular
magsafe charging animation
and it's charging at 15 watts cool
then there's accessories like this
magsafe wallet that they showed
boom it has all the corresponding
magnets inside to match up with the
alignment of the iphone
and when you connect it it just kind of
snaps onto the back in place
again somewhat firmly but it's not super
strong
and then it just plays the appropriate
animation so just to show you it knows
what accessory was attached
there's no extra settings or info on the
phone but it just it just knows then
same here with this whole magsafe case
it's a full case that has the magnetic
coils inside and you can see again those
magnets
super clear as day and when you put it
on the phone
the whole screen lights up because it
knows a whole case
is now on the phone now just in case
you're wondering why would you need a
whole magsafe case what's the point
so if you have the iphone and the
magsafe case you attach it
shows the animation realizes the case is
on a specific blue animation which is
cool for the case
and now you can still attach that puck
onto the back of the phone
and you're gonna charge through magsafe
so it's going through the case
so that's the benefit of the compatible
case and yet still
if you have this little wallet accessory
and throw it on the back here
of the case it still recognizes through
the case what accessory is happening
but if i try to charge through the
wallet
and the case it actually still
magnetizes
but it doesn't charge so it seems like
the limit to how many accessories i mean
of course the wallet is magnetically
shielded because you don't want to have
the cards inside get messed up
but even if you put a second thing on
the back i don't think that would be
very efficient
so yeah one layer of having a case on
your phone and still using magsafe
fine that's good um but yeah i think
that's the limit
too so anyway my take on magsafe
is it's it's kind of cool but not quite
as cool as i was hoping
mainly because of the strength of the
magnets it's
it's a little loose now we'll see if
third-party accessory makers can
use stronger magnets in their
accessories to better attach
to the iphone but i was imagining
something like a car mount may be coming
out where it's just holding it up with
magnets but
if you go over a bump like this magnet's
not going to hold it up so
i'm i'm curious how that goes with with
accessories you really want to stay
attached but even
look at this this is the the wallet
mount which you'd really want to stay
attached but even with this wallet case
putting it in my pocket it can easily
just pop right off just slide right off
and
that's your wallet that's like the one
thing you definitely want to
for sure stick to the phone the
strongest right so we'll see
we'll see what this ecosystem brings
another fun fact though
this is still technically it's all chi
it's a chi wireless charger so if you
have another android phone with qi
wireless charging
it actually magnetizes to the back and
wireless charges
many other android phones so if you're
into that you can buy
apple's wireless charger and troll apple
and take pictures of your
android phone wireless charging with
magsafe
every phone's had magsafe guys but
anyway that's that's it that's the first
impressions and hands-on
like i said i've been using these phones
now for a couple days so the review is
in the works but let me know what you
guys would want to see
in that video and of course there's a
bunch more coming up because
it's tectober that's just what's going
on right now so that's been it thanks
for watching
catch you guys in the next one peace